The U.S. is launching airstrikes right now
in Northern Iraq in response to the militant
group ISIS, which as been controlling parts
of Northern Iraq for months now. President
Obama, who had worked so hard to pull the
U.S. out of Iraq, authorized airstrikes against
ISIS if it threatens Irbil, which is the capital
of the Kurdish region in the North, or if
it threatens Mount Sinjar where thousands
of an ethno-religious minority called the
Yazidi are hiding out from ISIS. And this
seems like a really good thing for the Iraqis
who are behind Obama's red line around the
Kurdish region, but the thing is is that most
Iraqis are not behind that red line. Most
Iraqis in Northern Iraq have been living under
ISIS's rule for 2 months. There's no sign
that President Obama's airstrikes are going
to push ISIS back from there. So why did Obama
do this? Why did he draw a red line that just
protects a tiny sliver of the country and
not the rest of the country that has already
been conquered by this awful group. The first
reason is that the Kurdish region in Northern
Iraq is semi-autonomous. It has a stable government
of its own. It has a strong military that
has been pretty good at keeping out ISIS forces.
There are a number of Americans based there.
But the Iraqi government based in Baghdad
is a complete mess. The military deserted
en masse when ISIS invaded. The civilian government
has been on the verge of collapse for months.
America does not like the prime minister very
much, who they think has been making the crisis
worse. So Obama's calculation, which is cold
but probably correct is that he can save the
Kurdish region in the north, but there's probably
nothing he can do for the rest of Iraq. Good
news for some Iraqis, but for the many millions
who have spent the last few months under rule
by ISIS, there is no end in sight.